hey all the time once again for the
movie retrospective and once again we're
covering a movie that was sent to us by
Rob who sent us a lot of movies so thank
you very much Rob now this was one that
I mean it's across a movie yep
Russell Russell starred in this gym
front center and this movie impressed me
this is an awesome flick on on par with
like dual yeah or maybe like The Hitcher
yeah or I don't almost kind of like
maybe like The Hills Have Eyes gave me a
little bit of a The Vanishing vibe -
yeah arse poor loose if you want to go
yeah about a guy in his life he's from
Boston they got they're going out there
trying to get to California they gotta
go across the desert and they run into a
bit damn pack of wild men trucker and a
bunch of dudes from a town that are
helping him and they're just killing
like killing people and taking their
[ __ ] and it's a whole professional
operation and crustle has to rescue his
wife and so it's just a good flick yeah
constant action not a single boring part
in the movie and you're just frustrated
because this guy's help us all the time
you know but he's trying to get her back
they took his wife yeah pretty neat it's
good yeah this came out in 1997 it's
called breakdown in case we didn't break
say and it's really strange because when
this came out I don't remember when this
came out even though I was going to the
movies a lot during 90s time period yeah
but I don't really remember this coming
out but um apparently it was like a
really really big hit not only did it
make like a lot of money like it debuted
first at the box office but it also like
80 90 percent of the reviews were
overwhelmingly positive like you got
really really good reviews Roger Ebert
gave it a really good review like it got
pretty much all good reviews but I never
heard about it this is like a forgotten
master yeah and it's really weird it's
like so when we were watching it I was
like you know I think I might have seen
this like maybe on cable or maybe
somebody loaned it to me or something
like that because some of the scenes
looked really familiar but
I don't know so I don't know if I
actually saw it and just forgot about it
or if I was like confusing it with
another movie or I'm not I don't know
but um yes it was like a really weird
experience like seeing it and the weird
thing about it is that even though it
was a big hit in 97 it's like I feel
like people have completely forgotten
about it nowadays and it's awesome yeah
really good movie it's so good it's like
one of the like most tense [ __ ]
movies like you will ever sit there it's
like nail-biting yeah the actions good
acting is good the story's good crustle
is great in it there's even like a
couple little car chase type scenes
where there's it's like on par with like
maybe Mad Max 1 or 2 you know yeah it's
like all practical effects car crashes
and like all kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah
pretty neat and like all the stunt work
is amazing can't go wrong with this one
yeah I recommend it and so it was
directed by Jonathan Mostow or Moscow
I'm not sure he pronounced it this was
his first movie amazingly but sadly it
seems like he didn't really I mean as
awesome as this movie is it's like the
movies that he did after this were just
like not as good it's like he did his
peak he did you 571 which was like that
submarine movie which I remember being
ok that's right he did Terminator 3
rising machines
yeah that's okay you know so it seemed
like he just peaked early and then like
kind of a shame that that happened but I
also wanted to say too that the same guy
that did the score for Conan the
Barbarian also did the score for this
movie okay basil Polidori yeah yeah that
that Conan [ __ ] soundtrack is awesome
this this the soundtrack that this is
good but it's nowhere near as epic it's
going in
yeah well it's a different type of
moment you know I mean though I mean
that was a fantasy movie you can get
away with a lot more dot that dot it's
like you know with them see you know
this had you know you kind of a like a
really compelling like action movie type
of score yeah so yeah I like this
because you know this is obviously much
you know much later than you know Kurt
Russell playing like Snake Plissken in
those type of like action movie
characters in this one he's kind of
playing planet would she
actually yeah or just like a regular
dude who's not like a [ __ ] action
star and he's a little bit of a yuppie
yeah like they kind of like he's got
like the you know the Izod shirt or
whatever he starts off as a puss but he
man's up yeah like in his expensive car
he has to save his to save his wife yeah
also the wife is played by Kathleen
Quinlan who I knew her from Twilight
Zone the movie she played like the
teacher and the Anthony sending people
into the cornfield thing and she was I
think she was also in I never promised
you a rose garden which was a good movie
too but yeah and also JT Walsh is in
this playing one of the villains this
was actually I think it was his last
movie I think he died not too long after
this came out that dudes been in [ __ ]
everything man he was in a few good man
he was in good morning Vietnam he was in
Slingblade he was in [ __ ] Nixon
Pleasantville like he's been in all kind
of [ __ ] and so with kind of the star
power of this movie and how [ __ ] epic
and awesome it is it's just it floors me
that it seems like it's kind of
forgotten about yeah I don't know why
it's like I was looking at YouTube to
see if anybody else had reviewed it off
the shelf reviews it's like two British
guys and they usually do like a really
long I think they did like a 45-minute
you know review of this movie because
they really dug it that was one of the
really only substantial ones that I
found like so there were some like blogs
and stuff that had done like reviews of
it but it really seems to have like kind
of fallen through the cracks and that's
really sort of a shame because wow it's
yeah it's because it's really really
good like I said the tension is so good
and Kurt Russell I think is like well
he's usually like the best part of any
movie that he said I mean let's be
honest this is one of his best movies it
is because because you really buy that
he's just kind of this regular you know
yuppie ish kind of dude he's driving
this really expensive Jeep Cherokee that
he just bought
they don't go a lot into I mean
basically what the setup is is that
they're moving from Boston and they've
got new jobs in San Diego California
there is an implication that there might
be some kind of financial difficulty
with hence why they're moving or that
there might be some
tension between the two of them like
between the couple but they don't really
like go into it it's all just really
subtle and like really and which i think
is really good because you know if they
don't like smack you over the head with
like oh they're having financial
problems or oh this than the other thing
it's just they don't spend a lot of time
on that movie is not dialogue heavy it's
really nice that's what its strengths
yeah it's just real common sense
no-nonsense one thing happens after
another and dude has to deal with it
that's what it's about
yeah and so so you really kind of get
into his character it you know in the
sense of he's not you know Snake
Plissken he's not and he's just this
guy's driving this expensive looking
Jeep and he's a little bit clueless
about you know what he's driving across
this was actually shot in some of its in
Southern California so if it's Utah some
of it's Arizona so they're driving
across and there's like [ __ ] nothing
around and this is 1997 like he has like
a one of those old like bulky cell
phones but of course you know it doesn't
really work and it's like the [ __ ]
desert and the great thing about this
too is that it almost has a little bit
of a Twilight Zone type of thing at
least at first because you know with the
whole setup like the first thing that
happens they're just driving along the
road and he's like kind of distracted
he's like looking for something the
backseat or some [ __ ] like that and then
some you know some redneck in like a
like a beat-up old truck like kind of
pulls out in front of him and he almost
hits him but he doesn't hit him and then
like later on at a gas station like that
same guy is there and he's like super
hostile and everything yeah [ __ ] with
him yeah and he's like [ __ ] with him
and [ __ ] and you know talk about how
nice his truck is and all this other
kind of crap which is like brand-new um
stuff so then like further down the road
inexplicably the car breaks down and
they see it's great because like they
see the the redneck and the truck go
past and then he goes way down there and
then he's like starts to turn around
they're like oh [ __ ] now he's gonna come
back and like [ __ ] with us now because
he was so mad before and then JT Walsh
comes along in his big old semi and
seems very helpful
yeah don't spoil it though I'm just
saying it's like yes but then like then
this whole thing
happens why it reminds me a little bit
of the vanishing is because I mean at
the beginning of the vanishing if you've
never seen it where it's like it's a guy
in his girlfriend like a road trip
they stopped at a gas station she goes
to the gas station bathroom and then she
disappears and like so the whole rest of
the movie is like him trying to find out
where she went and then it's like years
and years and he never does and at the
end I'm not gonna spoil the end but they
they let you know like yeah where she
ended up with this one he basically runs
into into a band of [ __ ] desert
bandits is essentially what they and
it's like this little town that you
don't that's a creepy thing and that's
what I mean is where it kind of comes
off like the twilight zone a little bit
or like dual or something like that
because you feel like you feel like it's
a whole town but yeah and you don't know
like you don't know who to trust and
it's like you know some of the people
maybe they can be trusted maybe not
you're not really sure it's like you're
not sure who's in on it and who's not in
on it and so it's like it's just this
really really good like tense kind of
and you can like feel like Kurt
Russell's character I sees the name's
Jeff I think Jeff Taylor and um you know
really milquetoast kind of name and yeah
so it's like so you can just feel his
frustration because everywhere he goes
it's like is this person in on it too
and it's like he just doesn't know what
happens and like happened and everyone
is like stonewalling him and it's just
like this really is just frustration
this just gets bigger bigger bigger and
the he's just like figure out you know
it he's been thrust into this situation
where he has no IDs never had to
experience anything like this yeah this
is that's the kinda this is like two
people that just got kicked out of
Wellesley Massachusetts they're like
from Wellesley and they have to [ __ ]
deal with these therefore it's Arizona I
think it was Arizona um yeah it's I
think it was Arizona where they well
like I said they shot it in Arizona Utah
California but I think it was supposed
to be Arizona yeah I remember the plates
I think the place were car yeah we're
license plates for Arizona so he's in
the middle of Arizona with these people
that are [ __ ] hostile and he's trying
to figure out how to deal with it it's
just a good flick yeah and there's like
nothing he do and like I said they're
just tension just mountain mountain
mountain like it gets more and more
complex like yeah they're on a totally
different planet from this guy yeah like
who all is in on it and [ __ ] and then I
have to say
not gonna spoil like the very last shot
or like them what happens at the very
very very end but uh you know I've seen
like a couple of people say hi you know
they didn't really need to do that cuz I
was like a little too much and
everything like that uh I [ __ ] loved
it I thought it was great like I was
like yeah right you know it was in a way
kind of a stereotypical ending it was
yeah for the late 90s but it was a
really good one that's what the audience
wanted yeah that's what the audience of
the late nineties wanted yeah that's
what they gave and I didn't really think
that it was over-the-top or not
believable or anything like that kind of
reminded me of like I said it kind of
reminded me of uh dual or maybe like the
car yeah demonic car kinda movement it
took place a lot in a desert yeah I'm
driving you know and a lot of survival
it was like an action-adventure survival
movie and to me it seemed good it was
just as suspenseful as dual I thought
yeah and like I said it had a lot of The
Hitcher in it as well
just in the sense of the villains and
you weren't really sure who was the
villains or who was like all in on this
[ __ ] and you know what I mean and they
and you know the some of them were
really menacing and some of them not so
much in the orbit like Cheryl's Have
Eyes the original Hills em yeah they
weren't [ __ ] inbred [ __ ] yeah it was
like a regular dude just regular people
but kind of wild too they were kind of
like bandits or pirates yeah and
particularly JT Walsh's character I
think like he was like the best one in
it I think like other than Kurt Russell
because he was like a very complex kind
of character and he was just man he was
just like such a great actor and it's a
shame that he like [ __ ] died right
after this came out he didn't really
seem all that old in this the main bad
guy yeah yeah he's good the trucker yeah
yeah so it's like like I said it was
like a really interesting like a very
nuanced had a kind of a wild west feel
yeah that as well but yeah it's like
it's just really really really good and
I it's just a shame that I really
appreciate Rob sending it to us because
I probably never would have sought it
out on my own because you know it's like
I saw so many movies in the 90s i very
well might have seen it and just
forgotten about it for whatever reason
it almost kind of like a debt almost
kind of like a cowboys in indian movies
where you got greenhorns falling into
the hands of wild Apaches dynamic but
yeah it does have like a little bit of a
western day i feel it was it's kind of
like a spin-off on that but there they
weren't indians of course they were just
regular white people from the [ __ ]
desert and they were [ __ ] I think
they were [ __ ] criminals you know
yeah a little bit like deliverance like
deliverance yeah I mean not quite that
extreme yeah you know what I mean we're
like that that that type of thing where
it's like hey you're City [ __ ] yeah
not supposed to be around here we're
just gonna like well they were making a
living off of [ __ ] people over yeah
well because normal to them well yeah
because they live out in the middle of
nowhere and they're just like hey every
now and then like some with a curse
potterson yeah like stop or upper middle
class person drives through here like on
a road trip and it's like no one's ever
gonna like you list for them or not been
defied we wouldn't be able to find him
out there and wouldn't be able to find
him in the desert so so [ __ ] like that
used to happen of course well yeah me
still be going on yeah I'm sure it's
probably less nowadays but it's kind of
based on the old ideas of those old ends
where people would check into an inn and
they would never would check out all the
ones on those roads which myself yeah
and ya know yeah and then they would
just erase the [ __ ] ledger or have
them sign in on the never saw yeah
yeah and then investigations before this
had all happened you know back in the
1800s and stuff then they'd find debt
you know a hundred people came up
missing
through this hotel yeah weird looking
creepy woman like even up through the
like the 70s and 80s and [ __ ] like that
was happening you know and you probably
more of the 60s and 70s because people
are like hitchhiking out to California
yeah man they find bodies in the desert
all the time and a lot of them are like
not identified and who is because they
don't know Cesar's just somebody that
took off it's like hey I'm going to San
Francisco like cuz they're a hippie or
something like everyone can find them
had that serial killer that was taken
photographer serial killer taking models
out there to do photo shoots if I could
kill them yeah remember that dude
I may never get in a car with any
situation kind of like that yeah so it's
like that's it's scary because it could
totally happen like even nowadays yeah
cuz even in 1997 he had a cell for him
but it's still then if I couldn't work
out there you know what I mean but he
kind of he rose through the challenges
you could get around so please get
around cell phones
yeah we're using roses and guns you know
you could you know you could get around
cellphones today well yeah I'm sure
stuff like that still happens oh I'm
sure it doesn't find out the scale that
it used to but that reminded me when you
were talking about the ins back in the
old days that reminded me this like
really scary story that I read it was in
one of those Alfred Hitchcock Presents
you know anthologies I think it was
called the curious adventure of Mr Bond
didn't have anything to with James Bond
it was like older than that I think but
it was just like this guy and he went to
he was going like traveling to like a
series of three inns and they all had
these really really weird names and um
like the head of the traveler the rest
of the traveler and stuff like that and
it's like as the story it's long it's
like a novella and as the story goes on
you figure out like what the
relationship is between like these three
ends I'm like what they do with the
people that stay there and stuff like
that yes even in New England and stuff
where they were involved in the illegal
body trade remember that yeah yeah yeah
killing people then selling the bodies
to the doctors I mean that though it's
like I kind of get I'm not condoning it
but I'm saying that if you want people
to be doctors but then you have it be
the law that you're not allowed to cut
bodies up yeah then of course you're
gonna get a black market in that shirt
because I don't want some doctor cutting
on me that's never cut on a real body
before he's like well I'm just winging
it I've just seen the drawings you know
maybe we get very sidetracked off this
movie though you know I recommend the
movie I think the movie was a forgotten
classic gets a masterpiece should have
been up there with like dule yeah it's
like so hopefully like now that we're
putting a [ __ ] review of this up here
it's like people will remember it well
remembered and [ __ ] it might be I think
I saw that it was on to be yeah not
available on blue
and I don't think they have a very good
DVD DVD transfers I think I think he I
think he sent I think Rob sent us the
best DVD yeah Andy transfer and it
doesn't have a shirt on it's not the
quid no extras on it it's not quite the
right ratio for a modern television but
yeah you could say it was filmed in like
that weird I can't remember yeah I can a
Spectre a she shows that this movie
really needs a rerelease it needs a
blu-ray edition it really does and it's
like they need to like [ __ ] go in
cross all and go interview like some of
the other people that present and they
don't make movies like this anymore I
mean I think the kind I think the
audience's are hungry for movies like
this now because this is just like a
good like I said if you're pure of
adventure tension-filled but it's not
over-the-top it's not it's not like an
action movie like Fast and the Furious
we're like just a ridiculous [ __ ] ojq
this this is this is realistic yeah this
is like a realistic yeah there's some
stuff that it's like oh you know I'm not
really sure about that but it's like
it's not like supernatural or
superheroes or doing anything like that
it's like fairly realistic yeah
situation so you know if you're into
movies like that I should note that time
out London that magazine they pulled a
bunch of film critics and directors and
actors and stuff and stunt people and
they were asking them like what their
favorite us what their favorite action
movies were this was back in 2014 and
breakdown got in the top 100 so some
people remembered obviously but yeah the
stunt work on this is [ __ ] great I
don't know if Kressel did a lot of his
own stunts it looked like he did I'm not
sure hanging from this like hanging from
like underneath the [ __ ] they were semi
and [ __ ] like that oh yeah it wasn't
fake but yeah so definitely check this
out breakdown from 1997 really kind of a
lost classic yep and I just had a
[ __ ] blast watching this I was just
on my edge of my seat the whole [ __ ]
time yeah it's like I totally wouldn't
mind watching it a second time so it
might be on to be correct me if I'm
wrong so if you want to watch it for
free you can go in there just watch it
with a commercial or something like that
get all this dream it yeah I'm sure you
can find it somewhere so yeah definitely
check it out